well it took a couple of years in a big
dip in viewership but the NFL has
realized the public was turned off by
the controversy over players kneeling
during the national anthem today Roger
Goodell who runs the league announced
new policy banning public anthem
protests the players don't want to stand
they have to stay in the locker room or
their team will be fined already the NFL
Players Union has protested the rule and
New York Jets Chairman Christopher
Johnson says the team will simply pay
the fines if his players decide to
protest Jason Whitlock is with Fox
Sports 1 a frequent guest in the show
and he joins us now Jason thanks for
coming up no problem thanks for having
me so I read this Goodell statement
which seems fine but this line stuck out
and I'm quoting we're condena kated to
continuing our collaboration with
players to advance the goals of justice
and fairness in all corners of our
society which made me wonder are they
going to take positions on tax policy or
NAFTA next I thought this is like a
football league no they're not going to
listen I think Roger Goodell and the NFL
are trying to please everyone yeah and
I'm not sure if you can accomplish that
listen I think some people are heartened
that okay the players that take the
field will be called upon to stand and
respect the national anthem and the flag
but I think he's opened an opportunity
for a conversation about the players
that don't come out on the field and
that will drive a discussion about the
NFL that might be a bit uncomfortable
and not with the league once I really
think Tucker they should have done one
of two things they could have said to
the players look we're just gonna remove
the national anthem from your
involvement everybody stay in the locker
room we'll just do it with our fans yeah
that would have been option one option
two and it might have been the one I
would have preferred I wish he would
have just said look if you come out and
you disrespect the national anthem you
won't play you'll still get paid but you
won't play and so that will force NFL
owners and coaches to be a bit more
vigilant about who's on their team and
whether these players want to hurt their
team by you know honoring their protest
during the game
make some real consequences for that
protest and very so there's would become
we do that I mean that's such a that's a
kind of a brilliant solution why didn't
he do that I think the goal was to
please everybody players the left-wing
media that hates football and then also
trying to please be excellent the sports
fans and the actual consumers of
football who just want the players to
respect the flag respect the anthem and
put on an entertaining game people go to
sporting events to be distracted from
our politics and debates about race
shorts and football stadiums have been
where people of all kinds of different
backgrounds economically raised politics
all come together and root for a common
team it hasn't been a place to go to
discuss sports
I mean to discuss politics that's right
and I yeah I think it's great to have a
respite from all this insanity Jason
Whitlock host of speak for yourself on
Fox Sports one one of our favorite
guests great to see you thank you